astronomers report that the universe is
dying and we only have a few billion
years left to live with that in mind
let's waste an hour of that together
[Applause]
all right it's essentially a guy at the
office one of our writers Brian Kelly's
really bummed out about that really he's
like a couple of billion years Oh what
do you care
yeah no kiddin jack up those credit
cards yeah oh yeah I won't have to pay
Donald Trump of course in the news yes
thank God Donald Trump Donald Trump
still refusing to give any details about
his policy plans everyone else is saying
what they would do after being asked for
weeks Donald Trump still has not said
specifically what he would do as
president yeah
Trump apologized saying when I announced
I was running for president I had no
idea people would take me seriously this
is stunning
here's know what to do
[Applause]
before you that's my move is prompt now
moving forward and firing people
you were looser Hillary Clinton in the
news Hillary Clinton has finally agreed
to turn over her entire email server to
the Justice Department yeah Clinton said
she was reluctant to do so because of
state secrets and because 30 percent of
her emails are nothing but the smiling
poop emoji I use that one a lot too mo
the best as of this morning speaking of
Hillary Clinton asked this morning
Bernie Sanders is leading Hillary
Clinton in New Hampshire yeah yeah so
screw those emails from when she was
Secretary of State I want to see the
emails Hillary sent out this morning
yeah definitely can you imagine the
email she sent seven points behind
Bernie Sanders that's incredible looking
forward of those maybe not a smiling
poop emoji it's just come out that
before Pope Francis became a priest he
broke up with a serious girlfriend to
instead join the church yeah he broke up
with his girlfriend yeah man Taylor
Swift just cannot catch a break
[Applause]
I never do this now let's think about
the logic of that joke for a second he
dated Taylor Swift 40 years ago exactly
but people were still like oh that's
good
she's an immortal obviously she is
immortal he's one of the emojis she's a
she's a Highlander yes
you lost me I don't know what I love
whatever I never watch out into that I
don't know what Highlanders alright no
you know you're like we gots you were
reading books reading books I was a jock
on the big team on the big on the sports
ball team on that Sports 2 team see that
was a real sports - back in the day Jeb
Bush in the news Jeb Bush says we may
need to send more troops into Iraq to
stop Isis yes he said this in a speech
entitled what's the worst thing that can
happen when a president named Bush sends
troops to Iraq an unfortunate title for
that speed
hey English Parliament like my joke that
was very well gone
hey you'll like this Maria Sharapova and
Serena Williams are the highest paid
female athletes in the world after
hearing this Ronda Rousey beat them up
and took their money toward my
whole-grain egde the wildfires in
California is getting pretty serious
they're now starting to burn marijuana
farms the fires being put out by 200
firefighters and 8,000 volunteers
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]